hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
she is a comedian she's a queen
she's got her hand in the pickle jar and
guess what
she's a woman we have miss cracker with
us on today's episode oh
i can't believe this hasn't happened
already but it has and i'm excited for
you to listen to it we talk about
everything
her experience on drag race all-stars
getting ready for it
her experience in the pandemic her
interest in art
i mean you'll hear about some popsicle
pandemic art that she got really into
that uh
pretty inspiring to say the least also
her upcoming holiday album with jujube
also her upcoming podcast so many things
an incredible uh queen awaits you enjoy
this episode of not too deep
with ms cracker
[Music]
miss cracker the beautiful hilarious
being that you
are thank you so much for being here i'm
so excited thank you so much she's a
woman
tm you know i love it
now how yeah what is in your personal
contract on
how quickly into anything you do that
you have to get your catchphrase out
you know i say it immediately to wake
myself
up it's my icebreaker for me so
yeah have you you can try to get me to
sign a contract
to not say it and see how that works out
how i mean okay that is one of my
questions in the entire drag world
there's so much about like marketing and
branding do you consciously think of
catchphrases or are they like
organic things that happen that an
audience kind of catches on to and then
you realize
afterwards i am so glad that you
asked that question because
uh my co-pilot caitlyn who's been with
me for a long time
uh she taught me one of the most
essential things about
branding and that it is a response
to your audience and so
when they love something and they
respond to it and they like it
then you absorb that into your brand
you don't invent something and then
force it
young people does that make sense that
makes total sense
well that goes into my whole you know i
want to know how
miss cracker the entity the brand
was created for you take me back to the
beginning of starting drag where was the
seed planted for you
well i had never had any interest in
drag
whatsoever like one of the things that
always makes me laugh
is uh gay comedians and um gay male
comedians
and um a lot of drag queens will always
be like
oh you know me i was wearing my mother's
heels when i blah blah and i was not
that person
at all you know i i had i didn't it
didn't strike my fancy at all
um i was like super gluing
um feathers to my boxers like i was
doing random things
but not like drag things so um
how it started was i saw this guy
struggling home in the snow
with a bookshelf and i was like hello
i'm a good samaritan
i'm gonna help him with the bookshelf so
i was like hey let me help you we got up
to his place he turned on the lights
and the whole room was filled with wigs
and i was like like i was horrified i
was like
listen i'll do a lot of things but
putting a wig on your head that's wrong
wow this got specific real quick yeah
exactly
from a general story about me this
became about you somehow and i don't
like it
um so but it was too late like
we were already we already knew each
other we were already neighbors
and every time we ran into each other or
went out for coffee he'd be like you
should try
drag and i said um yes
which is gay for no
um dude i mean we're like yes girl of
course i will and
um but finally i had to make good on
saying yes
i tried it one time uh this person
painted my face
uh turned me around in in the office
chair
and i was like oh my god this is
incredible i love this and i became miss
cracker and that person became bob the
drag queen and the rest
is herstory wow okay yeah i have in my
notes i've been doing some research that
yeah you met in the blizzard
and helped uh help up with the bookcase
and that was
your chance meeting uh yeah and and so
from there bob put you in drag and then
was
the was the mizcracker personality did
it just organically appear
when the drag was put on i think the
personality
is just my personality when i'm excited
to be around
um as as a nice jewish boy i'm generally
pretty miserable
so you know my voice and my
mannerisms reflect that and uh
when i'm in drag i'm just so excited
yeah i think
that excitement is the is
the what people would call the character
the personality it's just
me on drag this is your brain this is
your brain on drugs
and that's what it looks like so okay
what
is the experience going on drag race
season 10 for the first time
how many times had you auditioned before
you got on
i had auditioned one time before
and i just didn't really know
who i was before and
i made this audition tape that was sort
of based on what other people
told me i should do and it didn't
work out so i sort of set that aside and
didn't audition again
and then my friend caitlin said hey
look what if you did a tape based on
your brain
and what you want to do i was like well
that sounds like a better deal
so uh yeah so i did that
and then i got on and
um again a lot of the things that i put
on that tape
were things that my audiences had
responded well to
um in real life so again i wasn't trying
to invent something new and i wasn't
trying to force anything on anybody i
was just like
hey look this is what it works you know
yeah
i just saw you post a video recently
where some you gave advice about
uh when you're making an audition tape
for drag race don't
try and go high production value
really make sure that it's yourself and
i think that advice is you know
it's seemingly so obvious but i think
in that world because it's so
competitive people want to put all the
bells and whistles
into something not realizing like the
real gold is just you
as you is that something that you kind
of
learned through your first season on
drag race
it's something that i learn every day i
knew
it's something that i should have known
um a lot earlier
but i think what it comes from is this
question like what does drag have to
offer that other things
don't like if you want to see something
really slick
and uh high production and amazing go
see a michael bay film you know
yeah like if you want to see um
uh incredible dancing and long legs go
to see the rockettes you know
what is it what is it the drag has to
offer and it's that this
like me and you together and just
our personalities and my personality and
us
feeling like this is a good moment um
so i slowly every day i have to reteach
myself it's not about
the look it's not about the production
it's not about all of that
it's about am i coming across to you
and i if i can come across you on zoom
right anything is possible
so it's just like yeah i kind of i kind
of learned like your question was
did i learn that in season 10 i had
already learned it but season 10
like reinforced that they were like
um season 10 taught me that you could
show up with amazing clothes and
if you didn't feel confident the amazing
clothes wouldn't matter
hmm and there and that was my yeah for
you going into that
knowing that uh you know bob had gotten
you into drag was there
i can imagine a lot of pressure going on
drag race to represent not only yourself
but bob
and there's kind of this you know uh the
i i wonder if there's pressure in the
community because of such a
you know known name that you're
associated with
it was kind of like um when your older
sister goes to high school
yeah do what i mean like when you show
up as a freshman
you want all the teachers to be like oh
you know i know your family blah blah
and it was less about what the audience
thought but i wanted to be cool enough
to hang out with my big sister
and i think that's where the biggest
pressure was because i didn't even know
what the word audience meant yet i
hadn't been on television
and i didn't even know about that
pressure yet but what i did know
is i wanted to make uh my drag family
particularly bob proud and i wanted them
to feel like
um i belonged as part of the household
you know
yeah it must have been an interesting
experience because i'm
such a big fan of you because i think
you do you're incredibly smart
and you have a great sense of humor and
you're also very self-aware but you seem
very critical on yourself because you
hold yourself to a high
standard as do a lot of uh drag queens
so it's so interesting to watch you
and what was your experience watching
you
after the first season aired what was my
experience watching
uh yeah
my experience was just
i don't know a fascination i think
because i was watching what i always
knew
of myself um and then
that was being paired with the reaction
of the world for the first time
and uh yeah i just learned
that all the little things that i
criticize myself for as a super
self-aware super
hyper self-critical person all of those
things
may not be as important as i thought
they were
because they didn't seem to be important
to anyone else but me hmm
that's a big thing to realize and you
got to realize that
with everyone with the national audience
yeah
it's kind of like uh when you i think in
contemporary times
when you come out of the closet and no
one gives a [ __ ] um
and it's because you know everyone
is more involved in their own life and
they are on yours so i came out in
season 10 and i was like
i have all these flaws and everyone was
like we don't care
yeah you're like let me present all of
these to you before you can even say
them so that i am in control of my
narrative here and you can't criticize
me for anything because i've already
seen it said it done it lived it
everyone's on their phones like oh weird
cool you know
no okay you you do season 10 and then
you
you did you get a call to come back for
all stars how did that work out for you
yes i got the call uh okay the root call
and uh it was uh it was like such a
uh what a cis male day it was for me
because um i was in
london and my sister
just got a call from her doctor and he
was like
you are pregnant congratulations like
you've been trying you've been through
such a
huge journey and i was like and i just
got a call
i'm gonna be on television oh my god how
do we celebrate
what does that mean it's just like you
just couldn't let her have a day
she had like five minutes she was like
she's like we're gonna remember this day
for the really
hello oh just kidding it's about me
no but honestly um it was it was a
really huge day like
she found out that one of her dreams was
coming true and i found out
that one of mine was and uh we were just
in this
uh london hotel room dancing around and
oh yeah that was a good that was a good
day that sounds very beautiful
now when you get the call are you
immediately excited
is this something that you knew that you
wanted to do if the opportunity
presented itself or
did you have hesitation because it is
such an
overwhelming and i imagine emotionally
taxing
experience as a whole yeah
um i always say that rupaul
is like your bladder in your 30s okay
when she calls you go
and that's the thing it's like if you're
if you're like i don't know if i need
the television i have my
own powerful brand and then the real
moment comes and
rupaul calls and you're like yes please
yeah if there were questions and there
were like my co-pilot caitlyn and i
would go back and forth
like you already had a great showing do
you want to risk
uh you know having one that isn't as
good
you know those down days and the updates
like you've improved so much like isn't
it time to show the world
we had the back and forth and that all
ends when that that invitation comes
from
um miss charles what do you think
have been in going into all-stars the
biggest growth that you notice about
yourself
in terms of your drag if there was
anything or if you were exactly the same
with no
evolution whatsoever i think the
biggest thing that i had learned was
that it's okay if you're unhappy it's
okay
if you doubt yourself it's okay if you
don't love yourself
yet it's okay if you don't have
faith in what you can do you can
step over all of that and
go far i thought you had to fix all of
that before you did anything before you
tried anything like you had to sit at
home
and like brow beat yourself into
self-love
first but then i learned like oh like
it's almost time for the show
i hate myself all right let's do it
that is one of the wonderful things
about watching it
is that you get to experience the real
side of
of the the insecurity and the the trying
that happens and yeah the mental
gymnastics that you probably have to go
to to work yourself
into a confident state for whatever
you're doing uh
does comedy help you there
i mean i think that comedy helps you
anywhere yeah because
being able to laugh at yourself uh
gets you through all those things that
you just mentioned all those challenges
that you just mentioned
um can be eased a little bit
if you can inject a little laughter and
that goes to
whether you're dealing with
self-confidence issues or
dealing with a pandemic if you can if
you can find a way
to laugh then i'm sure there's some
neuroscientist somewhere that says
you know you need that dopamine in order
to function
so i think it's a real i i would like to
declare that it's a medical fact
that laughter is this that's medicine
yes so you grace are treating people you
know
all the time trying to remind myself
yeah no because i
i feel you know like you i get so much
serotonin
from watching uh you perform that it's
like yeah
if you can give that to someone else
what a beautiful gift right um
now did you uh
afterwards oh one okay let's talk about
the
you made a public apology on the the
show
to another queen what is what is it like
not only making an apology to someone
but to do it on such a
public scale oh what is it like to
apologize in front of four million
people yeah
um god it's just like uh
in a way it's kind of cleansing because
um you so rarely get to
speak from the heart and uh you kind of
have to
go there when you when you apologize
like
there's a lot of times when people will
say something and you can't respond
um because you don't want to like
they'll say something negative and
you can't respond because you don't want
to give that negative attention
like that negative energy attention but
when it's time and you get to speak from
the heart
it actually feels good so that makes
sense
you're not this is uh i'm curious about
all of it because yeah
i imagine that you guys shoot for hours
and hours and hours and things get cut
down to maybe like two percent of the
actual experience that you have there
and so when they do show a real moment
like that one that is
a real human moment outside of all of
the the bells and whistles of drag
it's very touching and it's very
regardless of whether you're a fan
of the show or not just the actual human
interaction is a very sweet side it
reminds people
that you are a complex human being with
feelings and emotions and thoughts and
insecurities
and all of those things which is why the
show i think is wonderful
yeah it was something i got to do
outside the show too because i was able
to do it like
you know as the show was airing i was
able to uh call
and text and tweet and like all like
all the different ways that we uh
communicate with each other um
like i got to do all of that and it's
like
i don't know i think people forget that
there's
nothing more cleansing than just being
able to say hey guess
what i'm sorry i was wrong yeah
i mean you save a lot of breath
some people are like listen i'm sorry
that you feel this way
because what was happening was i was
doing this and it's like that's a lot of
talking
yeah you could just be like hey guess
what mia culpa
yeah i [ __ ] up and you know i know it
and i need you to know it
um that's beautiful okay we're gonna
take a quick break when we get back i
have to hear how you've been handling
the pandemic i will tell you i cannot
wait
okay we'll be right back we're not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two
things a big thank you for listening to
the podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here
in this not too deep world we've built
and you'd like to leave us a review that
would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise
maybe just good or otherwise would be
appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay um you're in the bronx
in a pandemic how has this been for you
the last
few months because it's been an
opportunity to see how creatively
people can adapt to this situation and
i'm curious what your experience
has been the last few months i mean my
experience has been so wild
i am a doer yeah and
one of my one of the pillars of my drag
is that i get in drag
and go out into the world and meet
people in person
and have that connection that we were
talking about earlier
so to have that leg chopped off
was just horrifying and so i ended up
doing all this crazy stuff like i
built a small town of tiny model houses
out of popsicle sticks
okay um and i was like tweeting them
like here's the progress
you know wait for any for for a bigger
reason for a production or just to pass
time
express some art yeah just because
i need to make all the time
dude i mean you're very you're i mean
you're so multifaceted because you are
truly authentically interested in art
and creation as much as you are funny
and uh sarcastic so i'm yeah i'm curious
how that's expressed itself while you've
had to stay home
yeah first it was the model houses and
then um
then i just started uh still doing it by
the way
but uh i started um sort of delving into
my drag
and figuring out what i wanted to create
uh if i wasn't creating shows and that's
why i totally forgot about all this
um i made these new singles um for the
holidays i made
i made one with jujube yes the queen
herself um one by myself
and i'm launching a podcast so
now now that's my tiny little town is
these these projects
that's fantastic have you always been a
big advocate of the holidays um
i the holidays are a huge thing in my
family
okay um because my mother has seven
brothers and sisters and i have like 26
cousins
yeah so it's like
just the simple fact of us gathering
makes it a huge deal sure and
so yeah i think about the holidays all
the time
especially in a in a family that's mixed
christian and jewish because you see two
worlds
meeting um and different kinds of
celebration happening
so yeah for me there there's something
that's
really complicated and uh
i think a really beautiful time of the
year
very cool and what does the family think
of the persona
miss cracker oh i'm like my family is
extremely supportive of me
yeah i've i've performed at uh
weddings within my family and
uh i've done cameos for family members
have you charged them for it
well of course not but i will charge you
at cameo.com that is a that's a
resourceful outlet
in these trying times i get it
absolutely
yeah um but yeah no my family has been
beautifully
supportive and that's because um as much
as i'm strange and multifaceted i think
everyone in my family is too so we give
each other room for that
that's very cool um in talking about
your holiday single is there anything
that we should know
to expect from get me the [ __ ] out of
here yeah
um there's so many songs about how
uh beautiful it is to get together with
family and
friends and um i remember
like before i went off to all stars i
was like at this big dinner with a bunch
of friends and loved ones and i was
looking around and i was like oh my god
i hate this and uh i just like i wanted
to write about that
feeling like even though you love your
family you could
kill them and uh we've all been there
like no one needs to use the bathroom as
much as you do
during a holiday what you're doing is
you're going to the bathroom to be like
yep and this song is that moment where
you have
like close the door you're fake flushing
the toilet you know what i mean
yes they're like something hasn't agreed
with my stomach i need an extra 10
minutes
exactly exactly it's like
what's going on in there i know you're
not really reading the new yorker nobody
actually reads the new yorker
you know i love that um
now because you've uh had to sort of
adapt to
quarantine pandemic living what has been
your relationship i'm curious with
social media do you enjoy it
do you participate in it do you find
value
are you following are there like people
that you love to follow do you hate
follow anyone
that's like 20 questions i don't hate
follow anyone
because you know i spent enough of my
life
uh just focusing on stuff i didn't like
yeah you've liberated yourself of some
pettiness that's very beautiful
yeah i've whittled my social media
down muted it down good to
like three funny people and a fitness
model
and i think that's what i mean yeah yeah
it's just like yeah uh god my friend
izzy uncut is like a dumpster fire of a
person
and has the funniest twitter and i don't
even look at it on the app
i'll be like in the morning with my
coffee i'll open my laptop and go
wwe
backslash easy uncut just to see like oh
you're right
real housewives is a wild you know
like i just like so that's my
relationship with
social media let's call let's use a 2019
word it's
curated oh i like that very much
i like to share but i don't i i don't i
don't like to
yeah you seem like you have a respectful
relationship like you participate but
you're not
overly indulgent it doesn't seem like
obsessive
you know and i live there that's good
good for you i know i
i've become very fascinated with
people's relationships with social media
this year i watched the social dilemma
and it got real into my brain and then i
got real worried
about humanity and the the fall of it
because of these little boxes we carry
around
did you did you change anything that you
absolutely behave
yeah okay i just wanted to know i i
thought you were gonna be like since
then i
only use my next flip phone yeah no i
have uh changed absolutely nothing i
only have the conscious awareness
that i should probably change something
eventually
that's that's me in the movie okay have
you seen okja on netflix
i'm writing it down it's okja
it has tilda swinton in it which the
deal is sealed
and it is this like
rallying cry for treating animals um but
it's
like it's a little fable it's just like
a little fairy tale but the lesson is
how can we treat animals better how can
we treat them like
we are now and i was like my life has
changed
all right seamless uh kfc
like it was that moment but for for all
those who are listening watch that movie
and see what it does and get back to me
because it's a good one i'm curious to
do a little social experiment on myself
with that
yeah i'm i'm also really fascinated
because you do have so many interests
like you're very into
food and art and culture and you're
doing um
these new series where you're
interviewing artists is that right
and then you also have been on the bon
appetit
channel and you also write about
activism
and so you have this wildly beautifully
complex
like universe that you kind of create in
how do you balance the things like like
writing
a piece about the community and activism
versus like
celebrating national pickle day can you
write all of that down because i'm
working on my resume since i'm like
basically unemployed right now you just
made me sound like super good
and doing all this research it's so cool
to see and i don't know that many people
or they probably do if they are obsessed
with you that you have this side of you
that is very cultural very artistic very
um
you know it's not only real housewives
all the time
so i'm i'm fascinated by by how you
balance
that okay i guess the key word is
curiosity
okay and i did i was not always as
curious as i
am i had a hundred year old boss
when i first moved to new york and he
had this publishing company
that was always like well-respected but
teetering on the edge of bankruptcy and
he was so happy and i didn't understand
how you could be like basically broke
um and so happy and he was like i'm
curious like i
publish whatever fascinates me
and i was like it got into my head
and i realized i want to do projects
that make me curious and make me
fascinated
and that's sort of the core so
um all the things you mentioned i don't
hold myself to any one thing
only the things that the only theme is
that they all sparked some interest
in me um and i hope that other people
feel that they can do the same thing
like
i'm not i'm not a chef and i'm not a
curator
and i'm not um i am not a makeup artist
um but i am curious about all these
things and i
want to show people that you can sort of
dive in
yeah just because you're curious and as
for the word balance
um when it comes to balancing them don't
balance
because balance is for um the
the quiet life
imbalance is where the interesting stuff
happens oh
i like that also um i would beg to
differ a bit
on you being a makeup artist because we
do have a hilarious connection
miss cookie is my ex-boyfriend i know i
know i know
i was i was like how do i bring mom
we're basically like we were almost
related i know
i did you know i did good
makeup yeah um
yeah but i i do want to say
that that's not where drag lives where
drag lives is in the spirit of the queen
and
that queen had a lot of spirit miss
cookie
oh my goodness you unlocked uh a
pandora's box
how did you feel seeing that i was so
proud
we're on good terms and so yeah i
watched it and i was so excited and he
had told me
that he was on the show but he couldn't
tell me anything else about it and so
yeah when that episode airs i was just
screaming at my tv
i was so excited for you guys and i know
that he's a very
outgoing person and i thought they
edited him to seem very
reserved and scared and so i was like oh
i see where this is going
it was beautiful stunning what's funny
is that he
he was like shaking at the beginning i
think that
that natural yeah he was over i think
that natural outgoing spirit that he has
when
he holds the camera on youtube
it was a lot different when there were
seven people holding a camera
right in his face yes you know he was
like wait a second i don't edit this
video
someone else is going to edit this but
then he like found his footing
and that's great it was great
um okay you grew up in seattle
i'm curious how do you describe seattle
i mean she used to be
[Laughter]
do what great mean seattle used to be
great
and um if you want to get a sense of
what it was like i think that
uh what's the one um
sleepless in seattle that's the one
because everyone used to listen to talk
radio
religiously and if you wanted to tell
your loved one something you would do it
over talk radio for real and i remember
watching that in the movie and being
like that's how we do in seattle
you're like she left me but i want i
want to
play this song for her and she's in the
car and she's like oh my god
that was seattle amazing now
yeah is the parking lot of amazon
microsoft and starbucks i see um it's
not
the same as it used to be and seattle i
say this out of love
you know i i was rooting for you we were
all rooting for you how
dare you let portland
come up farther than you
as a cultural asset to this nation how
dare you amazing
now also because you've done a lot of
different
series like uh review with the jew and
tutorials
do you feel obligated and have you
watched the other international
franchises of drag race
oh yeah i did a review of um
a review called high tea of drag race uk
and i have to say that was one of the
most exhilarating drag experiences
because i'm so tired of looking at
american queens and i'm
not i'm not alone in that we all are
even
all american queens are tired of looking
at themselves and to see
a new like uh a new boil of drag get
lanced into the world i
i just was like yes i i love
i love some of the the franchises for
sure yeah
very cool um is there anywhere that you
think
should be featured as a franchise that
hasn't
been featured yet any area of the globe
that you've been to that you think the
drag community is
very cool or perhaps not as known as it
should be
i had the most wonderful
experience in chile and there's a drag
queen called cote miller
uh there who i was like
this lady needs to be on drag race
really and so if i could see i could see
uh
drag race chile and um
if she ever hears this like i uh her
outfits she made all by herself she made
all her hair
and designed everything and i
bought her clothes off of her person
every time she entered the dressing room
i even wore some of it for all stars
really five so i mean there's drag
talent all over the world but i would
love to see drag race chili
amazing um now what can we expect from
your new podcast that's in the works
because we have a trailer out but the
episodes aren't out but maybe they'll be
out by the time this episode
goes up yes uh so the episodes are going
to be out on
start coming out on december 7th but uh
really
she's a woman is for any human being who
looks in the mirror and says she's a
woman
it's a very inclusive podcast we're not
trying to define women we're trying to
break apart the definition um and it's
just
stories of incredible women who've done
amazing things
um women that you could meet on the
street
uh business women that you have bought
things from and didn't know their
amazing story
so there are a number
of drag comedy podcasts there are a
number of drag podcasts that
interview other queens and i kind of
wanted to
break out and look at
a world of people that support drag
women
who make up like a million and nine
percent of our audience
um we uh drag
plays off of stereotypes and ideas of
women
and it may be time for drag to give back
a little bit
and so i want to you know be a part of
that
process that sounds so cool it sounds in
line with what you're talking about just
following your curiosity
yeah i did this show um american woman
in the uk and europe and
for it i had all these interviews with
great women that i knew
and i wanted to never stop doing those
interviews because i learned so much
and then i was like wait i don't have to
stop i can make
a podcast and that's what it is really
amazing well everyone should make sure
to go
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
get everything set up for yourself
we're going to take one last break when
we get back i have a bunch of questions
from
instagram for you and they are as you
can imagine
all over the place diverse very diverse
so we'll be right back we're not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
okay ms cracker before we get into these
internet questions i'm going to ask you
the two questions ask every single guest
that is on the podcast and the first is
who
alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti
at oh alive or
dead that i could throw cold spaghetti
at yes ma'am i thought you were going to
do a positive thing i would have like
one answer
but a negative thing like my mind is
blown
well you could decide to make it
positive it could be some sort of
celebratory but it's entirely up to what
your intention is
no no let's let's decide who we want to
throw cold spaghetti at
um uh
oh i really
this is a bizarre one okay um but uh
i would love to throw cold spaghetti at
thomas edison
um i don't believe we've ever had that
as an answer
do you know what i'm getting today all
of the packages by the way
there's been like three packages so um
we'll have an unboxing in a minute
no uh thomas edison and and it's the why
that counts
uh she got all of her ideas from other
people
gave no credit and she uh
was abusive to animals and has all this
status as a person
that uh you know was inventive and
brought light to our world
but really led a life that was like
pretty cruel pretty problematic
yeah and pretty pretty problematic and i
i think
thomas edison is held after such an
investor but i
want to throw warm spaghetti at nikola
tesla
um yeah who was
more brilliant um and didn't try to take
any credit at all and
uh yeah that's what i've
this i didn't expect to get such a
diverse education
during this podcast but i thank you very
dearly for it
yeah you're welcome yeah the okay the
other question ask every single guest is
to tell us your worst
pant [ __ ] story or a close call
situation but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
for example
mine is college jogging front lawn
angry in the tsa
one love that you had an immediate
memory that came to mind
and two that sounds like a single on
your holiday album
angry in the tsa born in
yeah i love it okay let's get into some
instagram questions for you
um the first one is
how did you get past all the cattiness
and game play
of your all-star season so gracefully
oh first of all thank you for the
embedded compliment
um second of all i'd like to say that i
i'm graceful and i'd like to say that a
lot of the queens on the season
we're graceful but here's the thing
about drag queens
um especially on drag race we're trying
to get through the day and
show what we can do yeah um and so for
all the people
i think of alexis mateo that were like
slinging mud
at alexis mateo like on the show and
off and during airing and um
like think about that for a minute she's
trying to get through her
day and yeah maybe she's making mistakes
um and maybe there's a lot of cattiness
around her
um and maybe she's like feeding into it
but you know there's a lot of pressure
yeah um
she's just trying to get through her day
so
come on you know sometimes it isn't
great sometimes it's just
you gotta soldier on you know yeah
sometimes you're too tired to engage
with it at all
right uh someone wants to know what is
your makeup or skin routine outside of
drag if you have one
neutrogena neutrogena neutrogena
i use neutrogena wipes i use neutrogena
face wash i use
neutrogena moisturizer i use like
on the spot neutrogena like acne
treatment
i like wow hello somebody because
that's my routine and then sunday riley
once a week
the good jeans nice very nice
uh someone's to know what's your
favorite behind the scenes moment of all
stars five
i'm sure oh yes i was like i'm sure it
has something to do with juju
my favorite behind the scenes moment of
all stars 5
was when all of us were
sewing our minds out
like getting ready for that uh backyard
uh barbecue ball yes and juju does this
like gesture
like she she can't take it anymore and
we thought that she had stormed out of
the room
to just like recuperate she comes back
with six tacos
from craft services eats them all
and takes a nap wow i just remember
being at the sewing machine like
what what pill do i need to take to be
in that headspace because that's
what that's my favorite the seeds all
starts moving
that's so pure it's so good
this is what i need right now yeah pay
attention to your needs
that's the lesson that juju tells us uh
someone wants to know what's been your
quarantined guilty pleasure
have you been watching anything have you
been obsessed with anything have you
been
eating anything get murdered
it's like i listen to um crime junkies
and i watch cold case yeah uh i
i can't i can't get enough and uh it's
to the point where
it's like i'll just be like just passing
out
in my apartment and i'll hear i swear to
god i hear my door opening i'm like it's
time
i'm gonna get i want to get ready now
but i still i can't stop i can't stop
watching and listening
yeah no um i'm also i have to like
delegate that to certain nights when i
know that i'm in an okay enough mood
that i could fall asleep after this
otherwise
i'm just like staring at my ceiling all
night there's a new documentary series
on hbo that just started called like
murder on uh something beach
uh and it's really fascinating i saw
something about that okay
yeah that's my recommendation for you
it's very interesting
five minutes i'm diving into that uh
someone's to know
what recipe do you want to cook on your
next insta live with carla
oh um what recipe do we do i want to
choose
um you know this is i want to learn
this is so terrible but uh
so stereotypically but i love an amazing
bagel and it's hard to get one and i
wonder if you can make one at home
and i want carla to teach me oh yeah
that's what that's what i want to happen
and uh we'll have to do some kind of
camera trickery because i'm sure there's
a whole
long process but i want to learn from
her because she has upped my game
that sounds incredible have you always
been interested in cooking
i have uh when when i was little my
sister and i
used to uh make uh dinners from around
the world
for our parents and uh so we would get
gather recipes from different countries
and
attempt them and so now i get to do that
on on the youtubes so how cool what a
great little idea too for anyone that's
struggling in quarantine to find like
cute things to do for their significant
other or their family
sunset magazines from the 70s just pick
one up and
shablam you're ready someone asked
what has been a positive of social
distancing for you
a positive of social distancing for me
has been not having to come
up with excuses to not
go do you know what i mean they're like
oh we're doing this and that
you know you should come down you're
like i can't i'm like so responsible
i wish that i could but i wish that i
couldn't you know yes
yes so great being able to say no
i think is just like to anything is
the blessing of quarantine yeah i'm a
hundred percent with you it's been a
as an introvert it's been a wonderful
wonderful thing in my world
uh so yeah someone's to know what's your
favorite look that you've ever done
my favorite look i've ever done
um i think right now it's my
uh all-stars five the
faberge egg because it's so stupid i
loved that so much
just the silhouette of it coming around
the corner
because i'm from seattle we have the
iris clam which is basically
uh a giant clam and someone is
inside it with just their legs sticking
out it looks exactly like
the faberge egg except with a clam
instead of an egg
and i think that must have been in my
head from when i was a kid
and i was like are we doing it yeah
amazing
okay someone asks mary [ __ ] kill i
oh these are so hard but this is with
food
mary [ __ ] kill turkey chili clam chowder
chicken noodle soup oh wow
well mary chicken noodle soup because
it's always going to be there for you
and chicken is low calories and i need
that right now
there you go um and then
it was turkey chili well [ __ ] lamb
chowder
you know what i mean like
there are jokes in there that we don't
even
have to do you can fill in the blanks
yeah kill kill turkey chili everyone
knows that it's beef chili
yeah oh okay there you go um
the angelina of the uh is beef chili
the jennifer is turkey chili uh
oh someone's asking what's the favorite
small venue that you've been to
favorite small venue that i've oh i just
threw my coffee
all over the floor oh no i was so
surprised
favorite small venue
i mean my favorite small venue that i do
will always be barracuda
in new york 23rd street um or excuse me
22nd street
um and it is the place to go to see
who's
next in drag because the girls that are
no longer there
are somewhere and the girls that are
there are going somewhere
um besides that i guess it would be
sweet bar uptown
um and that is literally like someone
put disco lights in the starbucks and
it's the size of my thumb
and it has great shows oh how cool
okay here's the last question for you
before we wrap up
uh someone asked when getting ready for
all-stars what's one thing you told
yourself
advice-wise
one more thing uh or maybe let's say
let's because we can i feel like this
kind of advice could
expand to like real world everyday
situations what's one
piece of advice i guess having done also
going into it
yeah that you would give someone
entering a situation as stressful as all
stars well jujube gave it to me
is that if you're stressed you're doing
it right
so a lot of times when you get stressed
you're like i must be doing things wrong
because i'm so stressed out right now i
need to step back i need to back off
but actually the thing is if you're
stressed you're doing the thing
yeah what i mean so don't be afraid of
stress just
run into her i love that it shows you're
caring about something yeah
there's nothing wrong with caring
there's nothing wrong with being afraid
and there's nothing wrong with stressing
it's part of the life i love that
i think that's absolutely wonderful what
a great way to wrap up ms cracker this
has been so fun
before you leave um we give our guests a
little gift for making time for us
and it's a personalized digital fortune
cookie from
us to you that i believe has been
emailed to you
all right here's my fortune cookie happy
belated national pickle day to you
miss cracker and that's all
that's all thank you so much
of course first of all how did how did
the pickle become
so embedded in the brand ever since i
first put that pickle costume on i like
what
go back to what i first saw it on the
hanger i was like that
is going to be in my life you know
yeah it was tailor-made and then it was
just like
by the way she was not tailor-made that
thing fits
like a magnum condom on it anyway um
so uh yeah as soon as i saw i
i saw it i loved it and then the world
saw it and liked it and
i was just like any chance i can get to
reinforce her
i do because there's no such thing as
too much of a good thing
i love that i love that now where can
everyone find you where can they find
the music the podcast all the things
that you're up to if they don't already
know
well just find me on miz underscore
cracker
just like the snack on instagram and uh
it will lead you to a world of music
if you don't like me there's jujube if
you like
want even less of me there's she's a
woman which has
the stories of incredible women from all
walks of life
and uh yeah there's twitter yeah there's
youtube yeah there's
uh a website but if you go to the
instagram
that is the beating heart so just do it
amazing make sure you go check out
everything that miss crackers is up to
she's
absolutely wonderful endless great
advice endless
lulls and uh endless great conversations
that i'm so excited for you
to embark on thank you again for making
time for us ms cracker
and we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep
deep goodbye deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen lani eunis post
production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music